The Immortal.
When nightmares come to life, you find out you're not immortal!
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike.
I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
So are you immortal?
Are you not immortal?
That was a confusing box, right?
I can confirm that you are certainly not immortal in this game.
In fact, I feel like you're more
mortal than I am in real life in this game.
Yeah, he had glass bones and paper skin.
Yes. Uh, this is a, uh, well, rather than talk about what it is first, uh, anybody ever heard of
what it isn't?
No, but anybody ever heard of the Immortal before?
I certainly didn't hear about this game.
I didn't know anything about it going into it.
No. Yeah, I hadn't either.
And I don't think it's, like, a big thing, but it's another one of those games where, like,
someone gets to put their name in front of it.
Like, Will Harvey's computer classic, The
Immortal. And it's like, remember we, somebody else did that, and we were like, isn't that
like a Sid Meier thing?
But, like, apparently this was just a trend back then.
Because, like, I don't know Will Harvey either, but I looked up on Wikipedia, this is his last game.
So, uh, Well, I know, I, I know that EA back in the day was like, uh, oh, like, you know, art,
like, video games are art, artists should be credited.
And, like, even in the, like, even
in the instruction booklet for this, they have, like, like high school photos in there of the
people that made the game and just like, okay, guys, calm down.
But yeah, but I mean, that's the
exact opposite of what they are today.
So it's like, yeah, but I guess that makes sense.
Electronic arts, artists, um, maybe that's, maybe that was what they were going for.
But yeah, I'm not ragging
on this guy. He, he, he made a pretty cool game here and he had a couple of other interesting
things. He had a lot of, like, internet stuff after this, where he, like, founded a company that
was just like, first it was about network latency problems.
Then it was about instant
messaging. Then it was about 3d worlds for socializing, but, you know, obviously not like
second, uh, second life or something like that.
It was just more for, I guess, I don't know,
businesses or something like he just kept trying new things with computers.
Uh, I don't know if any
of those things were successes or not, but I think it's just interesting that like, you know,
now exploring this podcast, we're seeing so many people who get the, uh, the moniker in front of
the title of these games.
Uh, the immortal is a pretty cool title though.
I think this is one that
would just based on the box art, like make me at least look at it in the store.
I think the,
the box art is pretty cool like that.
It's, it's not very, it's not as cartoony as everything else.
And it's got intrigue.
And how many games do you play as like a really old person?
Yeah. You're so old.
He was like an old man.
You're like old.
I don't know. I thought that was interesting.
Like I, I actually feel like every game that we
play as you are like in your prime, like either a kid or, or an adult who is, you know, like setting
out on a grand adventure that only this person's equipped for.
This is like the exact opposite.
You are, uh, you know, a really old unnamed, yeah.
Unnamed, um, wizard who, or, or apprenticed
to a wizard who enters, um, a dungeon, uh, of sorts, a cave, I guess, uh, because they're
trying to follow, uh, I guess messages that they were tracking down from, uh, their master
Mortimer and, um, Mortimer like sets them out on this journey, but like, we don't have
much information about this guy.
And all we have the ability to do is like shoot fireballs
and fight. But we learned that we're in like some kind of isometric trap heavy action adventure
game where there are as many ways to die as there were in shadow gate.
Yeah. Um, but it's, it's interesting cause it's so differently, it feels so much like
shadow gate, but it plays so different.
It kind of really threw me for a loop being like
this action adventure shadow gate.
Like it just didn't, it took me a while to adjust to
that. I don't know about you guys.
Yeah. I thought it was in like shadow run for a second, just with all the, I mean, it's
really just the isometric viewpoint and, uh, the, the, the vibe is more like, I guess mature
is feels like a more like between the marketing materials and, and just sort of the first few
moments of, of exposition and gameplay.
It's like, Oh, this is a, this is a different vibe
than usual. Yeah.
And I guess in shadow gate, like you have all these ways to die that are based on
choices you made, which sometimes can feel, you know, crazy that like, Oh, that led to
this or whatever. But in this, it's like, there's a lot of ways to dies die.
And sometimes it's because of choices and sometimes it's cause you just, you're playing the game.
Yeah. You just walked in the wrong direction and you could have, you know what I mean?
It feels a little cheaper to me in this game that the shadow gate like elements in this game feels cheaper to me
than it does in something like shadow gate.
I think that in both this game and in shadow gate, it becomes pretty apparent very quickly
that they're going to try and kill you in as many ways as possible.
And I think, yeah, in the first
five minutes of this game, you will die in five different ways.
Yeah. Um, so you just kind of take that into account.
Sure. But I guess what I'm saying is that like shadow gate, I'm like, all right, I know
that like, if I do this, that might be some kind of trap or if I do that, it might be like,
I'm going to try it and let, Oh shit, it was a trap.
But like, this is just like, all right,
I wonder what's over. Oh, there's a trap.
I couldn't have possibly seen it.
There's no way I could have known it was there.
Joe, isn't that because shadow gate is kind, you know, obviously it's a point and click game,
but if it's more turn based in nature, whereas, uh, the immortal is real time adventure
game, uh, where you are experiencing these same puzzle mechanics of like using things
from your inventory and applying them to the environment.
Yeah. But because it's happening in real time, there's also just like, like you said, you're just
walking and then you die, you know?
Yeah. Right. Like so many things were invisible that it felt like it just felt like the game
was attacking me, you know?
And like, I, I didn't even really have time to adjust for
it. Like why make it invisible?
I guess that's maybe I'm getting like into much deeper things
that we're trying to get into right now, but like, it just felt cheap, cheaper to me a lot
of the times the way you die.
And so there's two modes of the game, if you will, the, the game
starts in the isometric viewpoint.
And, uh, that is where you're just kind of navigating through the
actual, um, cave or dungeon.
Uh, there are traps, switches, pits, all kinds of environmental
hazards. There's also, um, like other, like, so there's two different forms of enemies.
There's enemies like goblins that will, um, approach you and force you to go into the second mode
of play, which are these one V one closeup duels, uh, that we'll get into in a bit.
Cause I think that deserves its own section, but then there's also these bats and, uh, other,
uh, like, mostly bats.
Yeah, mostly bats, but like, I think you're actually like, they're
described as vampire bats.
So like, could they turn into just Dracula's as well?
Or like, why are they, you know what I mean?
Like, it's like, would they, would they wear the cape and
everything too? Or are they just like, I don't think they do that assistance to vamp to Dracula?
Like I think like, you know, you could use, I think vampire bats are also a colloquial
term for like some regular bats in real life.
Yeah. I think there's actually like a species
of bat that's called a vampire bat and they, and they just attack people as frequently as
this wizard gets attacked.
Yeah, but they do, they do have capes and they do have weird
Eastern European accents.
Got it. Great. Because the bats in this game, uh, they don't trigger
a one V one combat.
They just are in the, uh, isometric view.
They just, yeah, they just kind
of, once they, once they fly around the room, but once they latch onto you, they're on you
and you must, um, shoot off your, uh, your second means of attack other than in the one
V one duels, you have this fireball projectile, which is not great.
Uh, it, it's, it's tough
for, it was tough for me to really aim this thing.
Uh, and I don't know if that's because
of the isometric or because of how enemies move around and such, but the bats became
a nuisance because the bats feel like at least on some level, they are a, uh, a don't stand
there and, and wait, uh, like timer thing where it's like, you know, Hey, Hey, you got
to keep moving. You got to stay active.
Right. We don't want you to just sit in here.
But at the same time, it's like, okay, well now there's bats here and it's likely to take off
just as much of my health as a fight with a goblin.
And like, that doesn't feel equal.
Yeah. I think it's good because in the beginning I thought that this was just going to be a thing
that was going to pester me the entire time.
And I did not know that I could kill it with
the fireball. Um, so I would just, I would just get destroyed by these things.
Um, until
I realized like, Oh, I could shoot it.
And I think once you realize that you can just shoot
it and yes, it's a little harder to aim, but it's not as big of a deal as like the first
impression of like, why is this thing always nagging me?
And the majority of the game happens in this isometric view where you are, you know, where
you're doing the puzzle solving.
This isn't something where you're, uh, prompted by texts
and such. You, you go into your inventory to find specific things and use them in specific
locations, but you have to be in the right spot, uh, triggering the correct events.
And some of them are, are very, uh, you know, I don't want to say complicated or anything,
but they're very, uh, nuanced puzzles that aren't just like, okay, I'm here and I pulled
this item out of my inventory.
You do need to know a little bit, uh, that I feel like in
some ways can only be found out through the very detailed manual.
There is a manual here
that, uh, looks like it was two separate, uh, booklets.
So there was like the instructions
booklet, uh, for the game that explains like the, just the basic controls and how to do
stuff and includes a complete walkthrough.
Like you would have in a strategy guide for
the very first level of the game, just to kind of tell you, you know, go through this
door, open this chest, fight these two goblins, like just literally explaining all the various
scenarios you can get into because the first level of the game is kind of a tutorial of sorts
of the kinds of things you'll encounter in the game.
But then there's like this second
book, the codex of the serpent is what it's called.
And it sounds very epic, but it's the
entire game, including that first level again, in the form of hints that I feel like if you
don't have this book, a lot of the puzzles are going to go over your head or you're just
not going to think to be like, well, how was I supposed to know?
I need to stand on this
square and pull out this thing.
I wonder if this was almost like a DRM of sorts.
Absolutely. Right.
Because there's enough text in the game already between like, which
also give you hints, like being in, having your dreams read out when you rest and, uh,
just the, each moment of, of dialogue between different characters.
There's a lot of text here.
So they could have put all this stuff in the game, I feel like, but yeah.
Yeah. This other book that you're talking about, this, this came with the game?
Yeah. Oh yeah. Yeah. Not a separate strategy guide you buy.
This is like another booklet.
Um, similar to how like, you know, some games come with maps and such.
Like the Final Fantasy, uh, that always came with like a little, uh, first dungeon walkthrough.
Yeah. But that I think was in the instructions manual.
I don't quote me on that. I don't have
a boxed copy. Yeah. That was the same, that was the same booklet.
Yeah. Yeah. But this,
this is like, um, Joe, since it doesn't seem like you got a chance to look at it, uh, which
is fine because game FAQs.
I'm looking at it now. But yeah.
Game FAQs nowadays will have
all the information that you would have needed anyway.
But for players, it's interesting because
it has like, uh, one thing that I thought was a neat addition in the, um, in the early
levels is those will the wisps that attack you.
And I was reading the strategy guide and,
uh, you can control these will the wisps.
Like instead of them attacking you, you can cast
a spell so that they basically, uh, you know, uh, surround you and create, uh, like a force
field before you take damage, they'll attack and they won't last the entire game of course.
But it's a neat little thing of like, not necessarily a mandatory puzzle, but rather
than being attacked by these things, you could turn them on your side.
So it goes through this
whole like text of legends have told of wayfarers being attacked by will the wisps.
I reckon such
stories were the products of childish imaginations.
And this goes on for like a full paragraph.
But then at the end, it's just like, maybe I can devise a spell to bring them under my control.
It's like, it doesn't really leave much to, it's like, you know, you'd only have so many
things in your inventory at that point.
It basically held your hand there at the end.
However, uh, you do still have to make the connection of what a will of the wisp is because
I would have thought they were just fireballs.
That's true. That's true.
But I think like, that's a recurring thing with every single one
of these, uh, things in this, in this guidebook is it's like, if you just read enough into it,
you will know what exactly to do in that exact circumstance, provided that you have all the
stuff in your inventory.
Because an interesting part of this game is that like, there's nothing,
like, there's nothing you shouldn't pick up, right?
There's nothing that like, uh, you know,
I'll leave that behind because I think my inventory is getting kind of full.
Like, no, you should pick up every single thing.
I think the manual tells you that too, of just like,
there's no such thing as a bad thing in this game.
But like, for instance, in level two,
there are these, uh, uh, green slimes on the ground that, uh, you know, if you touch them,
you'd, uh, you know, it's instant death.
There is a merchant that sells a, uh, a potion for it.
That's going to help because there is one particular room that I'm sure speed runners figure out an
exact way to skip over it.
But most likely this green blob would touch you if you, um,
if you didn't have this potion, he offers it for 100 gold, which is impossible to have.
So you have to refuse his offer so that he, you know, as like your way of bartering, you just like,
no, but he goes, Oh, okay.
Okay. Have it for 80 then.
And 80 is all of the gold that you could
have collected at that point in the game.
So if you missed any gold, you still can't afford it,
but you needed to pick up every single piece of gold in the first level in order to afford this
thing in the second level.
Now, could you refuse him again?
No, he won't. I mean, yeah,
that we won't lower it.
Continue playing the game.
Yeah. Cause that would be an interesting way to
teach you a mechanic is like, you have to refuse cause you can't afford it.
Now, you know, you can refuse and then you can do it more or something.
But I, I want to test this, uh,
that, you know, this way that like the game maybe held your hand with that.
I didn't get because I didn't read the manual, but the first part where I got really stuck and I had to look
up, uh, in game, uh, FAQs is at the end of level one, you have to go to this room with like a staff
and you have to, you have to, you have to pick up the, the amulet.
You have to hold it up to the light.
It asks you, do you want to hold up to light?
Yes or no? Yes.
Then you have to read the inscription,
but you don't read the inscription.
You say no to that. Yeah.
You do say no to that.
Yeah. Those things in that order is the only way that I could found to open the door to move on.
Was there something that taught you that?
The thing that teaches you that is that you burn
and are incinerated when you read the, uh, when you read the inscription.
And that happens at any point, any point in the game.
So that happened to me and I thought,
okay, so this is not the point where I'm supposed to use this amulet because I died.
I didn't think like, oh, I have to still hold it up to the light, but not read it.
I don't know. I, maybe that was
just me not trying every possible thing, but I was like, okay, this is not the point for it because
it's letting me read it.
And when I do, I die.
I guess what my point, my counterpoint to this would be is that each of these levels is pretty
self-contained.
And like, like Mike said before, like you have a very limited inventory.
So there's only so many things that you can do.
And also when you die, because you were burnt to a crisp,
I read the amulet, uh, inscription, you are respawned, not too far away from where this happened.
And even if you were to lose all your lives, you're just going to have to, you're not really
losing that much progress.
Yeah. I don't know.
I'm not, I'm not sure.
I, I'm not sure.
I agree only because of all the, you have to take this amulet.
You have to stand by the staff.
You need to, which, why would you know that?
It's not, you need to hold it up to the light.
It's not a staff though, right? It's, oh yeah, I know what you're saying.
I'm sorry. Yeah. Okay. Keep going.
The staff leaning against the wall.
You have to stand by this staff that there's no indication, unless it's in the manual or something,
like the staff gives off light that reflects off an amulet or something like that.
Then I, then corrected, but like you have to do that.
You have to hold it up to the light.
If you read the inscription, you die, which does encourage me to think, okay, the amulet's not it.
You know what I mean? Why would it ask you, why would it ask you to those two things?
Do you want to hold the,
the amulet up to the light?
So I get the amulet. Then why would it then ask you the second one?
I, I get the amulet.
I hold it up to the light.
This is exactly what happened to me.
I get the amulet. I hold it up to the light.
It asks me, do you want to read the inscription?
I do. I die.
Okay. Okay. Let me try not holding up.
I get the amulet again.
I hold it up to the light.
I don't read the description.
Nothing happens because I'm not in that room at that staff.
There's, there's too many layers there.
Like, I just don't know how to get all those things
together. Why would I know to go to the staff and do those things in that order?
Because it's in the manual.
Well, why did you use, why did you use the amulet at the staff in the first place?
I didn't. I Googled it.
I looked it up on F game.
I used the amulet just when I got the
amulet. I was like, what does this do?
And then I, I mean, I did that too, but I didn't
know to do it at the staff, you know?
I see. Can we go back to the staff for a second?
Cause I, I don't have that part of the gameplay
in front of me and I don't, what is the staff?
Are you guys talking about the, the light
that's shining through the room?
Is there, there's a staff?
Is that what that is? That's a light from the, that's the sun.
Yeah. That it's leaning against a wall.
It's a, no, that's a beam of light.
If it's a beam of light, then I get what they were going for.
And that would make more sense
because you're holding up to the light. That did not read like a beam of light to me.
It looked like Gandalf staff.
Okay, good. So, so I, I thought you were attaching the, I thought you were attaching
the amulet to the staff.
That is that may or may not be in a shaft of light.
No, there is a hole in the wall that is causing the sun to peek through that part at once.
Only one time in a millennium does it happen.
And you just happen to be here.
Uh, and now you,
it says, uh, this mechanism, uh, can be tripped every thousand years by light.
Use something shiny,
dot, dot, dot. So it's telling you to use the amulet.
And when you put the amulet up there.
That makes sense. But then it's still, it just, it hit me because that did not read as light to me.
It read as a stick, you know?
Yeah, I know. I hear you.
It doesn't, it doesn't look great.
I know what you mean.
Um, but okay.
Now that we solved that,
I agree with you that, uh, it sucks that the amulet, uh, that reading it causes basically,
it's like everything.
And does it like everything in the room just goes up in flames or something?
Like, what is the idea? Like you die by reading it?
But then like this sort of ties into the end
of the game though. Oh yeah, absolutely.
Yeah. Yeah. And you having tested
that and dying like tells you that you should not do that at the end of the game.
I don't know. Yeah.
It also tells you that you shouldn't do it again.
You know, to your point, Sean, that like,
uh, Joe, if you do it once and it says like, okay, hold it up to the light next time, just don't read
it, but hold it up to the light.
And you would have seen that the trap door opens to reveal the
ladder. But that, that's, that is what I did.
Just not realizing that that staff was the light that I
need. You know what I mean? I was like, where's this light that I need to, you know,
I understand. Also full disclosure, I've not, I did not beat the game.
So I don't know, you know, if this comes back and it's important at the end of the game, that's also something that
I did not. It's, it's very important, but, but we have to talk about the end of the game
towards the end of the episode, just because it's so nuanced.
And I feel like we need to get through
a few other things as well.
So like, I'm glad that we were able to dissect a puzzle on that level.
I don't think we can do that for every puzzle in the game, but you know, just, just to stay.
I'm going to go and do it. Yeah, sure.
Go for it. If you just stay on this exploration aspect of it,
right. You don't have to like go to the next puzzle after that or anything, but there does become this
thing with the goblins, uh, where at first they are just like a brute force enemy that you should
be attacking, right?
Like they, they are, they are on the offensive.
They tell you to stay away from
them. If you approach them, then you have to fight them.
I need, I need to chime in real quick
about the goblin thing.
So at, at no point in this game are the goblins, uh, are the goblins like
on the offensive.
You are in, you are an infiltrator.
You are invading their space.
They're in their own
little fight that you are not a part of.
And yet you massacre them in the first couple levels.
And so you are never in the right.
They were going to kill that, um, that other guy who
gives you the key in the first level.
You don't, you don't know who that guy is.
Like, that's just some guy.
Like they're always like warning you that like, Hey, don't take a step
forward. Like, Hey, don't, don't come near me.
And yet there you go.
You're coming near him.
Like, of course you're going to get into a fight.
Yes. I agree with you.
The goblins weren't
asking for it.
They were not. That's just those, the fantasy world rules where it's just like,
yeah, if it, if it looks human, but isn't like, we're just allowed to kill them in math
and we're still the good guys.
And of course the goblins evolved through the levels to be
something that like, well, there's this role, there's this war that they're having with the
trolls and you don't have to necessarily fight the goblins.
In fact, there are some that like,
you're just going to be in for a world of hurt if you try to, but the goblins are the introduction
to the other part of the game, which is this, you know, one-on-one combat system that, uh,
is nothing. It's not a real time isometric thing.
It is, uh, it's more like you're, you know,
uh, rock them, sock them robots kind of thing where like you have, that's a perfect description.
Yeah. You have specific positions that you can be standing in, uh, either attacking or ducking.
And depending on where the enemy is attacking or ducking and where you are, that, that will
register as a hit, a miss, or a hit in their favor, uh, towards you.
Because even when you try to duck,
if you are not ducking in the, uh, opposite direction of their, of the enemy's swing, you will
just be hit by their club or whatever they're attacking you with.
And so as a result, it's a very
involved combat system that happens incredibly fast, uh, at, at the beginning of the game.
Like, like with no warning, you are brought into a fight that you just don't have the muscle memory for the
controls yet. And so I don't know about you guys, but for me, this wasn't, you know, easily my earliest
death was just dying to a goblin in a fight.
Yeah. It took me a while to kind of get the feel of these
fights. And even then it's...
I just button mashed. And I was, at least for the first couple, I was okay
just button mashing.
I mean, I could button mash and get through one or two battles, but that would
lose some effect that by the third battle I'm dead.
Yeah. And I think I read this somewhere, but I, I
don't have it in front of me on my notes, but I believe I read that it's not just as the encounters
go on, but based on like the amount of fights that you have each fight, the goblin, like AI is more
intelligent than like the previous one.
So if you skipped the first two, the third fight you would
have had will be like the first fight of the game.
If that makes sense. It was kind of counting up based
on your encounters that they get smarter and smarter.
That's an interesting system in itself too.
Smarter and smarter.
What could they possibly, is it just like reading your inputs better?
I don't know if it's reading your inputs better, but I can tell you with certainty that button
mashing will not work beyond the first level.
Oh, I know it didn't, but I, I, I'm saying that my first
death was dying from a worm.
Uh, okay.
And that like the, my first fights were, were pretty,
were pretty survivable.
That's all I'm saying. Got it.
I guess I was just trying to play the game system.
And as a result, it was like, I, every time I tried to duck, it was not in the right direction.
It was like, Oh, I finally pulled off the duck, but I'm leaning into his attack instead of pulling
away from, uh, it reminds me of in final fantasy seven rebirth.
There is a like boxing mini game
that you have to do this exact thing in where you have to kind of like pull away from the punches,
but you have to know what punch they're going to throw based on this like small,
slight tell that they have.
And every enemy has a different tell.
It was like that level of
frustration where I'm like, ah, I, I, I just pushed the wrong buttons.
Like, because the way that you
duck and the way that you attack are somewhat similar because they're D pad pulls plus, uh,
the correct button input.
So sometimes my brain would just screw them up.
And what I meant to be a duck
would go for an attack, but I already knew that the enemy was attacking.
It created a lot of awkward,
um, encounters for me where I wasn't, I was losing a lot of health often because of how bad I was at
these combat encounters.
Maybe the avoiding the system kind of saved me at, at certain times then,
because I, I was just not really thinking about it as hard.
And because like you could just
like kind of brute force it for a while.
Um, I don't know.
No, I hear you.
I think I was in my own head too much.
If I, you know, if I'm being honest,
I think it was one of those situations where I'm trying to use the game systems and I just can't
even, I can't think like that.
I can't think about, uh, ducking versus attacking, uh, correctly
enough that I'm playing its rhythm style mechanic game.
I also think that the, the mechanics or, or the, the game systems that you're trying to play with
are just unclear, uh, like what, what you're exactly supposed to be ducking.
And so yeah,
I just didn't really get it.
Uh, yeah, I'm, I'm, I'm guessing, and that's something that I just, I just decidedly didn't
look at the manual for, but I, I'm assuming that's in there.
I mean, is it clear if you read the manual?
Yeah.
Yeah. But I didn't. I was like, I'll figure this out.
And I sort of did.
And that combat system remains throughout the game.
So the rest of any combat happens in the
real time space where you're just firing off your projectiles.
Um, you know, eventually you can do
other cool stuff like ride a magic carpet and, uh, um, use items in your inventory to cast specific
spells or, uh, turn enemies against each other.
These are all part of the puzzle mechanic more
than intended, like, uh, consistent combat solutions.
It's not, it's not like, yeah,
they're not systems. They're just, they're not systems puzzle, uh, like features.
So
so
But the first level, if we go back to that,
just because I think it's an easy, like, it's easy things to talk about.
The room with the arrows that shoot out if you don't walk in the intended path,
would you have ever even thought that there was an intended path not to trip off the arrows?
Like, they're pretty easily dodged, and it just kind of, like, it happens,
so I just thought, like, oh, this is that room where, like, it motion detects that I'm walking through it.
I'm going to assume that Joe didn't know that there was an intended path,
because that's, like, we saw that in the manual.
Yeah, you're exactly right.
I had no idea until this moment.
I just thought, yeah, this is the arrow room, you know?
Yeah. Okay, so, Joe, here's a solution that you definitely knew about
because it's communicated to you in-game, which is weird, right,
that there are certain things communicated in-game and others that aren't.
There should have been at least a hint for everything, I suppose,
but the shade enemies that appear in the dark rooms, right?
You're warned about that, so surely you lit those torches in that room using your fireballs,
so this way you can see those shadows. Yeah, well, because you get that note, right?
Yes, yes. Yeah, that dead guy is, yeah, yeah.
So do you think the game would have been better if it was more, like, you know,
exploring to find notes that almost, like, Elden Ring style, like, players left behind,
you know, these things that, like, give vague hints about, like, what's coming in the room ahead?
Should that have been a constant thing instead of just, like, randomly giving off?
I mean, I don't know if it has to be notes, but yeah, like,
maybe if I had read the manual I would have been a little higher on a lot of this stuff,
but, like, it's not just the puzzles for me, it's the traps that really frustrated me.
Where I'd just be, like, I'm just dead.
Like, I'm just dead all the time for things I can't see,
and sometimes it is like, oh, I can see it, and I can sit here and figure it out,
and then I can move. But doing that for, like, every, you know, what felt like every room,
every couple steps I gotta figure out what's next, it wore on me, I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, I agree.
I think that the, a lot of the sort of adventure game logic stuff is front-loaded,
and once you've tried to use bait in a random area and get eaten by a worm
or get incinerated by an amulet, you're kind of desensitized to that,
and, and it, like, when the future puzzle logic stuff, like,
running into a goblin that says that he'll never give you a thing,
and it's all his, and I'll never give this to you,
literally in the room before that, you find, or, like, maybe two rooms before that,
you find a ring called, like, the Ring of Complacence or something.
Yeah, yeah. Compliance. And it's like, oh, I should probably use this here.
And then you use it, and he gives you the thing.
It's not really that big of a logical jump,
but when you're just walking across a floor that has spikes coming out of it randomly,
and then you think you see a pattern, and then spikes just break that pattern and kill you,
like, that's annoying. And that just means that you're supposed to die enough and memorize the floor.
Yeah, and I, I do not think, uh, it's praiseworthy,
but it's certainly intended, right?
The game, the game was even promoted as such as, like, uh, you know,
you will die a lot, you know?
So it's definitely intended by the developer to, like, oh, you know,
like, they went through the trouble of animating a lot of these, too.
So it's like, look at all these crazy deaths,
and they were toned back in the NES version compared to the computer game.
But, like, I, I don't know how I feel about that,
because I agree that it's frustrating almost to a point, uh,
that makes you want to quit the game.
But it's not so punishing that, like, when you die, uh,
provided you have lives remaining, that, like, you lost so much progress.
Like, this could have been a much worse game if you only had one life,
or if you, like, uh, start at the beginning of, of the level if you died.
Like, I, I feel like there's something,
there's something about the way that they handle the fact that you will die often
that makes it, like, known between the player and the game that, like,
oh, this is intended, I'm supposed to be dying often.
Like, I, I, I registered that right away.
And I think it's, like, I, I feel like it might be this kind of
forgotten style of gameplay that comes out of
the, the, the world where people had only one game to memorize and stuff like that.
Then there, there probably is more of an audience for, you know,
people who, who want to, I don't want to say memorize a game,
but, like, want to get so good at a game that, like,
they know the levels inside out.
And, like, that was, like, such a bigger thing of, like,
really knowing, oh, like, this is where you got,
you got to do this, this, and this, and, like,
you got to, like, figure it out.
People, people would spend a lot more time in this game to learn it
and then show off to their friends, like, I can get through this.
And I feel like that's kind of lost on me these days
because it's just so removed from the way I play games now.
I'm going to grant both points that, like, yes,
I even went into it earlier in the episode that, like,
when you die, it's never, you're never losing that much progress.
But that doesn't make the frustrating moments less frustrating.
Yeah. To get into some of the later puzzles and such,
or not even that much later,
the Goblin King, when you run into him,
it's not an encounter you should take on.
And, in fact, if you wind up wearing,
you get a ring from one of the trolls that lets you look like a goblin.
If you wind up wearing that and talking to him,
that's an instant death as well,
so you can't fool him by trying to be one of the goblins.
But you have to do this thing where you plant,
you plant these spores on a dirt patch in the room,
leave the room, come back into the room with the Goblin King,
give him the water that you found,
and then, you know, for saving his life,
he gives you both a clue and a key.
But then, in the following level,
if you gave him the water,
he lets you pass easier
and warns of the trolls that are coming ahead.
So, there is some payoff here
between, like, choices you make,
that, like, you, you know,
there technically isn't just, like, one solution to this game.
Like we said, you could try to outrun those green blobs
rather than use the resist potion.
There are other paths.
It just makes the game that much more hard.
Yeah, I think it's funny that
just going off of your amoral nature
and how you're breaking into
this conflict that does not concern you,
that you then trick the king
into thinking that you saved him
and you had nothing to do with him being poisoned by spores.
Even though you were in the room just a second ago.
No, yeah, I mean, it's partially his fault.
He probably should know better,
but you also didn't correct him.
It's true. In, I think it's level five,
it might have been level four,
there is maybe, like,
the first instance that we have on this show
of, like, meeting the developers
inside the video game.
Did you guys know about this?
I didn't.
I, at this point,
I was just trying to get through it
and I did not finish the game,
but I did watch a later run
of this whole coffee thing happen.
Yes, so there, it seems like, you know,
you can find the room
and see the developers
who are in normal clothes, mind you.
They're not dressed up like wizards or anything.
And they request a cup of coffee.
And if you don't have the coffee pop beforehand,
you know, and the ability to make the coffee,
like, you just would think, like,
oh, they're just like, that's a funny joke about how developers are overworked
and they need caffeine to stay awake or whatever.
But you can actually bring a cup of coffee to them.
And by doing so,
they give you overpowering body odor
that knocks out every single enemy in the game
because you smell so much,
which is also probably a commentary about gamers on some level.
So, like, the devs really got in there
and made this.
I don't know about yet. It's so funny, though, don't you?
Well, I think the basement dwelling computer thing
was there right from the beginning, Sean.
Okay, all right, all right.
But that is, like,
that is just such an interesting inclusion
that, again, totally optional.
You don't need to find this little Easter egg.
Obviously, it will kind of break the game.
You still have to solve the puzzles,
but no more enemies to deal with.
And it's just one of those things that, like,
you know, again, even though these puzzles are a little, like,
use this exact thing at this exact spot,
there is a charm overall to the game
once you, like, once you've figured it out
that I think makes you want to keep going.
You solve the puzzle that was kind of annoying
and you're like, I kind of can't wait
for the next annoying puzzle.
I wonder what that says about you, Mike.
Yeah. Maybe it only says that about me.
I don't think you guys were agreeing.
Well, here's the thing.
What you're saying in the game you're describing,
I'm, like, really excited about.
I want to play this game.
And I'm not saying this game wasn't that.
I'm saying I don't think I gave it
the chance to be that.
And, like, when I started,
as I was playing it,
I was like, this is, like,
I'm really intrigued
and I really want to get further in this.
But I just wasn't enjoying
the moment-to-moment gameplay.
And, like, I almost feel like
the way you're describing it,
I want to go back and play it
with that in mind.
Because I kind of did want this
to be, like, what Shadowgate was for me,
but in a more action setting.
And I think I was just more disappointed.
But, like, everything you're saying,
like, hits the kind of thing
that I want to do,
but I just was not.
I was just getting all frustration
and, like, none of that satisfaction.
And, Joe, I think that's because
it's worth... Don't you think it's worth mentioning
that, like, the actual controls
of the game aren't all that tight
and that that creates
probably this experience
that you had where you weren't
exactly feeling it?
And, you know, like, I think, like,
I'm describing the fun parts
of the game, but it's worth mentioning
that it's not exactly
the tightest controls
we've ever seen. And the isometric isn't, you know,
is doing it favors
from a graphics department, surely.
Like, this game looks amazing
for an NES game. Yeah, it's a beautiful game, yeah.
Yeah, completely. But, like, I don't think
everything is pulled off
as easily as saying it
in this podcast.
Yeah, definitely.
And with the movement
and with the, like,
the goblin combat, you know?
Yeah. The movement I eventually
got used to, but isometric's always
a little weird
to get the hang of.
But, like, even once
I was used to it, like, having movement
that doesn't...
that isn't perfect
and having traps
that are, like, one tile off
from each other that'll kill you,
that's a recipe
for a little bit of frustration, too.
I think that the puzzle design
has highs and lows,
um, and you can really
start focusing on the lows
when you get speared
from the floor 15 times in a row.
So, I kind of agree
with both of you here.
It's funny, Sean is, like,
taking my position,
my normal position, where I'm, like,
I'm always, like, on the fence.
I did...
This was a very
charming game to me,
and it's kind of
up my alley
in a lot of ways,
but I also, like,
I also don't like
those little, like,
it's not just, like,
oh, I can't master this,
it's just, oh, I have to
memorize this.
So, I get where
you're coming from. Yeah.
At the beginning of the game,
as we mentioned, you don't have a name.
You see a letter addressed
to a man named Dunrick,
but it says to you
in the game, your name is not Dunrick,
so that's interesting,
right? That is the best piece
of writing we've seen
in a frickin' NES game
in the entirety
of this podcast.
I swear to God. It was an intrigue,
and you will eventually
meet Dunrick, who, surprise,
surprise, has been chained
in, I think it's
level six or whatever,
you have to give him
a ring in order to
gain some additional
inventory stuff that you'll
need later. So there is this thing
where, like, you're meeting characters,
you even meet his daughter,
right? His daughter is Anna,
the one that...
That is Anna.
Yeah. Okay, so basically,
you're meeting these people,
and you are trading
inventory for inventory
or using inventory stuff
to acquire new stuff.
So, like, you always have,
as long as you picked up
everything, you always have what you need.
But the reason why
I wanted to save the ending,
Joe, for the end,
is because you need
basically exactly
everything
and need to know
exactly how to use it all
for the final fight
in order to...
Yeah. ...in order to win the game
because there is no other way
other than by
finding out that you
don't have the
necessary item
to complete the checkpoint
in the boss fight
because the boss fight
is not a 1v1 duel
like we saw
with the other enemies
in the game is in the isometric viewpoint
a giant dragon,
you, and surprise,
the guy who you thought
was your master turns out he lords you in here.
He shows up as well,
but he only shows up
after a certain point
in the boss fight too,
so you have to kind of figure all these things out
of like, okay, now the dragon's going
to blow fire,
so I need to
cast blink
exactly, or you only have to
cast blink once,
but you only get
six exact uses
of blink, so if you can't,
if you don't use it
for each of those
six fire breaths
or you find out
that you don't have
seven of them,
you will die
at any one of those,
so you have to time those exactly correct.
On the seventh fire
breath, he does like a
double fire breath,
so you have to use
fire protection
for that in order
to make sure that you,
you know, just basically don't have
to, you don't have to use time the input anymore,
you just absorb the fire
for both those blasts.
Do I mention that the
dragon also fakes you out
on the sixth blast
where he does like a,
he has like this huff
motion and he goes
back for the huff,
but then he goes forward
without doing the flame
blast, and then he blasts the flame
as if to taunt you,
saying like, even if you figured out
the timing, I can still change it
at any minute. It's all crazy stuff.
Then, um,
uh, what is the guy's name?
It's, it's, it's long.
Just call him Mordecai.
Mordecai, all right, but that's not his name.
But it is with an M. Yeah,
it's Mordemir. Something like that.
Yeah. Yeah, Mordemir,
Mordecai. Yeah.
Mordemir shows up,
he tells you that this
has been his plan all along.
The game is called The Immortal
because this has
the fountain of youth
or whatever that he's been using
for like a thousand years
to stay alive,
and he needs,
uh, these dragons
like guarded or whatever
but this dragon got free
but now it's back.
He needs you to kill the dragon.
I wasn't really following here
and I'm sure you said it
more elegantly
but like, I did,
it did feel like it wasn't a problem.
Like, the dragon apparently like
burned his hometown
or whatever but like,
dude, this sounds like an issue
between you and the dragon.
Keep me out of it.
So, he needed you
because you were going to,
uh, you were going to,
no, I'm sorry, you, you continue.
Yeah, he cast the,
um, he cast thunder
which you also have to time,
uh, your dodges for that as well
using a totally different spell
but again, you, you have only these things left,
you know, it's kind of like
process of elimination
but again, how would you know
that he's about to cast thunder?
He doesn't say, and now get ready
for my lightning attack,
right? He just does it.
Like, you're gonna die.
You're gonna die. You're gonna be like,
ah, shoot, I should have used that spell
but you have to figure that out
so this is a very long fight
where everything has to go
exactly right
and requires,
you know, your own, uh,
timing mechanics. It's not just about having
the stuff in your inventory.
He then takes the amulet
from you and reveals that
the dragon will not kill,
um, the person who holds the amulet,
the thing you've been holding on to
the whole time and you have your last spell
which is some,
uh, magnetic hands
or magnetic power
and you,
uh, in, you know,
right before the dragon's
about to blow fire at you,
you grab the amulet back,
it blows fire directly on him,
killing him, and you are now,
uh, able to drink from the fountain
of the youth and you are young again
and you get to,
uh, and you're with Anna.
And now,
I understand where the title
The Immortal comes from.
Exactly, right? But how cool is that?
You're an old man
who turns young.
Yeah, but hold on.
Okay. The amulet thing,
I don't, does, from what I saw,
because I did not get to this part
of the game, but from what I saw,
you have, once you,
like, tank
that final fire breath,
that's when you use the amulet,
right? And then, you,
once again, you don't read the inscription
because you remember dying
doing that earlier in the game
when you were just encountering with your inventory
and that's when
Mortimer Mordecai comes down
and is like, you fool,
you had to do that,
we were supposed to do that,
right? Yes, that's true.
Okay, so,
that's, that's the,
that's looping it,
looping it back in
to the beginning
and I think it's just
a little weird that,
you know, you're like an 80 year old dude
and, uh,
you know. Yeah,
now you're getting, Anna wasn't old.
She's not old.
Uh, that is also the good ending.
There is a bad ending
when you don't help her,
but, and that just means that like,
huh, I guess it was weird
that my master who,
also, just another sidebar,
you're pretty old yourself
and you're still
this dude's like,
apprentice? Well,
yeah, when does the apprentice
become the master? Yeah,
but like, you're pretty old,
but like, you're not a thousand.
I don't think this guy
ever revealed to you
he was a thousand.
Yeah, I don't think you know
he's a thousand. But I'm saying,
him being a thousand,
he's probably skilled enough
to still have way more
magical knowledge than you do
and you're like, well, I still got more to learn
from this guy, whether you know how old he is
or not. I think at a certain point
in your 30s or 40s
you're gonna go off on your own,
you know? Like, even if you don't,
oh, he's still better than me,
but I could probably
wizard myself,
you know? I just assumed
that that was like
a part of the culture
of like, yeah, like wizardry,
you're never done learning
until like, you know.
But man, what,
what a convoluted
final fight
that like, must be amazing
for the one guy
who figured it out
and then everybody else
who read the FAQ
because they were tired
of getting all the way to the end
and dying.
Obviously more than one person.
Obviously it's a skill issue
for me, but I do think like,
I'm so conflicted
about just how awesome
it is to have everything
in your inventory
and just figuring out
the correct sequence of events,
but it is,
other than like some minor timing stuff,
it is just saying like,
uh, aha, but I thought of that
and I have this. Oh,
well that doesn't matter because I have this.
No, I have this.
It's like, it winds up becoming
an anime fight almost.
I think the framing
specifically, and I think at a wider,
in a wider sense, like if there was
any other time
that you used magnetism
or if there was any other time
that you used like the statue thing
and it was just
a part of systems
and then it's just
sort of emergent
that it would all happen
in the boss battle,
that would, I'd probably grant it
a lot more credit here.
And even just
a smaller tweak,
if it was just framed
that you now
had the ability
to blink,
not specifically
six charges of blink,
but that you just
had the ability to blink,
I think that
this would go down
a lot, like this would feel
a lot less contrived
than like once you
pick up the blink spell
and says, don't use it six times.
If you, like after that,
it's, you know what I mean?
Oh, totally.
That adds a lot to it.
I agree that it's a shame
that all of these
awesome spells
have to be saved
for the end and never taught
to the player ahead of time
or that there aren't
like more open-ended
solutions to this
other than just doing
exactly what the game
intended through
45 inputs.
Yeah. You know,
it's like at least
in like,
okay, so say like,
all right, we got Mega Man 3
coming up. So say if any
Mega Man game,
right, like the final boss fight,
you know, at least you have
like the freedom of movement
to like,
no one play
would look exactly
the same as another,
right? There's like obviously
like better weapons
to use against
certain enemies and everything,
but like the actual gameplay is unique.
Here you have the ability
to have movement
in this fight
because you've been doing it the entire game,
but they lock you
to this like little cliff
or island,
if you will, and like everybody
just has to stand in their positions
and act out
the part. Yeah.
It's all on rails
from here. But to talk about
the presentation and not just the
presentation of the
final boss fight,
but just in general of the game,
we, you know, we briefly said
that the graphics are awesome
and I agree with that,
but even just like the little touches
throughout of like
how realistic
isn't the right word, but how it's trying
to go for something
like that with like how
when a ladder
reveals itself, you can only enter
from that side
where the ladder is if you try
just to go to the other part.
Yeah, you just fall down.
it's another reason to die. Yeah.
Yeah, but like,
you know, it's a thoughtful touch.
There's that one part
where you're in the raft
and you're, you know,
with the current and everything
and it's like, you know,
I'm not saying they did a water level
or, you know,
like, you know, like look at those graphics,
but like I did believe
that I was rowing
that raft
and that there was
like a current and stuff.
Like, I think that, that glug glug
sprite that you,
when they,
when the thing, I forgot the name
of the enemy, but when that's chasing you,
that glug glug sprite
is like,
that's gotta be 60 frames a second.
It's, it's so smooth.
Yeah, the whole game
does run at 60. It's worth saying.
I'm sure there are
slowdowns if you cast enough
fireballs or had like a turbo
or something,
but I would just say
that like presentation
this game
is on another level
and that makes me appreciate this
Will Harvey guy
because, um,
while I don't think he did
the NES port,
which is impressive in its own right,
um, the original game
like clearly
is doing something
a lot earlier
than,
um, you know,
than what I would have expected
could be done for this kind of
hardware. Yeah,
I do think that like the isometric
style on the NES
is kind of unmatched
as far as
like detail
and, I mean,
like, what's this, it's like the,
was it like the
last level? Yeah,
that's what you're talking about
with the water, right? It's like the,
not just the rafts,
but like the actual vortex look,
like the, the shimmeriness
of it all and everything.
I mean, I think it,
it being this pulled out,
everything's kind of smaller,
like it gives it the ability
to look like, it's the closest
to like, oh,
I'm in this environment
that you can be,
you know, because it's not side-scrolling
and it's not
like top-down like a Zelda
where it's a lot more cartoony,
you know, there's, there's just that,
there's a texture to it all.
Absolutely. Oh,
jinx. I hope it actually
matches up in the
audio recording. It probably won't.
It'll look like I said it first
because I already
have the, no, I'll edit it that way.
Is there a,
you know, maybe,
you know, I'm actually going to skip these
questions for a second,
but for the, for the listeners,
you know, are,
is there like a,
is there anything
that when you played
this game back in the day,
right, how many of you
did persevere?
I, I would be interested
to know how many people picked this game
up, whether it was at Blockbuster on a rental
or got it as a gift
or bought it themselves
when they thought, saw the box was cool.
And because of like
the kid in me,
like I would have died
early on and I would
have given up. I would have been like,
man, this game is really hard
and I'm not going to get anywhere.
I did not like really
spend time with games.
I would just go back
to the classics that I
already knew I could beat inside and out.
I do wonder how many
of you, when you were young,
uh, beat this game.
Uh, because there are a lot
of times where like we
say, how did we beat these
games when we were kids?
I think it'd be more
impressive if you beat
this game as a kid
than as an adult.
Yeah. I'm trying to think of
what, like what I would be,
I had a game shark
growing up, so there,
right. You would have used
the game genie in this
case. Yeah. I,
I had a game genie too,
but I definitely use the
game shark more often in
that, in that generation of,
of, of games.
But, uh,
I probably would have cheated or,
or tried to cheat and
realize that like it just
didn't work that way.
Um, maybe that says something
about us as a generation.
Yeah. I mean, I remember so many times,
you know, cause my first console was
the NES and I played a lot
of Super Mario Brothers 3
and, uh, you know,
a little bit of Mega Man
and a little bit of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
And then I would just play
like minutes of every other
game and be like, I don't get this.
Like, this is,
this doesn't work. And I would just go back
to my three games.
And looking back, I really wish I had given
more of these games a chance
because I feel like a lot
of them had what I was
looking for. I just didn't,
I just didn't know I had
to like, you know,
as a kid, I didn't know I had to
get past some,
like, some thing.
You didn't believe in yourself,
Joe. Yeah.
That's what it was. We're talking about a
33 page manual
for this game.
I think that alone,
like, ain't no way I'm reading
that, you know? Like,
that's the problem is,
like, I remember
for the N64,
we got Quest 64,
which was like one of
the only RPGs
on the console.
And it was my first,
like, ever RPG,
other than, like, I don't consider Pokemon
an RPG.
But we got the
strategy guide with it.
They probably told us,
like, well, I didn't mean,
like, Pokemon in that regard,
like, not in the same,
it's not in the same difficulty class.
I know what you mean. But,
like, I'm sure,
like, the Toys R Us salesperson
was like, yeah, you got this game,
like, you're probably gonna want this guide,
because, like, we didn't own guides
for many games, but we had it for
Quest 64. And I still never learned
what I was doing, because I never read
that guide. It just wasn't going
to happen. That's crazy.
I wasn't gonna read books.
I read, I read strategy guides
and instruction manuals
for fun. Like,
just without, I don't know.
I did too.
I used to love that,
but everything I had
on the NES, I got from garage sales,
you know, so there were no manuals,
there were no cases, there was nothing.
But PlayStation stuff,
you read that stuff.
PlayStation stuff, I read the manuals,
but you didn't need to
by then. Yeah.
By then, the game told you
how to play. I just read the manual
because I liked to, like,
I read the manual because I was on my way
home from Blockbuster
and was too excited
and I had to, I had to consume
part of the game
in some way, you know.
And I just want to say,
I did have strategy guides
that I read where I read them so much
that the pages fell off
and I still have those strategy guides
downstairs in my basement
with like, isn't this a 100-page
strategy guide? Yeah, but I only have 17 pages.
And that's for,
unfortunately, games that I was,
good at anyway, like Pokemon Red and Blue
or Ocarina of Time.
Like, I just loved
revisiting the parts
of the game that like, I couldn't get to again
without replaying
the whole game. So I would just look at them
in the strategy guide
and stuff. It was like, I wasn't going to learn anything.
I just wanted to,
I like the pictures.
And I also like
when we get
near the end of the episodes
to do a little thing
called The Essential Games List.
The Immortal There's no doubt
that The Immortal
is an incredibly
challenging game
and at sometimes
a very, at some places
a very frustrating game.
The controls
leave a lot
to be desired
and yet
I like really
enjoyed this one
on a level
that like I usually
don't when we
like are, you know,
like we don't have that much time
to spend with these games
and as I was playing
The Immortal I was like, I know I'm not good
at this right now but I want to see
if I could get better at it.
Long story short was I didn't get much
better at it but I did keep getting
further and further
as I kept playing
and while I really
like this game
and probably
like I'm putting it
on my like, man, if I see this
in like a secondhand shop
I'm going to buy this game
because I'd love to
spend more time with it.
I don't think
I can actually recommend it
as an essential game.
I'm definitely recommending it
to people who are
listening to this podcast
and finding any part
of it interesting because I'm not
putting it on the essential games list
because the controls
aren't really the greatest.
I do think
that the moment-to-moment
gameplay isn't nearly
as exciting as kind of like
the rush you get in your head
when you do make forward progress.
This is the kind
of game that like is much better
looking back on
than while you're
actually playing it and so to me
that doesn't fit the essential games list
dialogue box
where like other
other RPGs
are maybe more
repetitive easier
and you know
not as challenging
in their like
puzzle solutions
and such but like those games
feel more satisfying
in the moment-to-moment
because you get you learn them quickly
you get better at them
and eventually master them.
I'm not at the master
part yet and I think a lot
of people who have
even beat this game wouldn't say that
they were masters
at it so much
as they were masters at reading
either the included
manual or some
game FAQ's guide.
So while I think it's an amazing game
that is very unique
on the system and I totally recommend
it to listeners
of this show I don't think it
belongs on our list
of the best games
for this system.
Sean? Yeah.
I really dig
the aesthetic of this game.
I think it's got
a great sense of humor.
I think it's a
very good looking game.
It and you know
it is very frustrating
and that's
even with the
the very generous
like continue system
and the
and even
something we didn't mention
that if you do fall down a hole
a specific kind
of hole you can
sort of save yourself
by getting
another rhythm game
right and sort of
swinging yourself back out of the hole.
I just wanted to get that out there
that that's another
little bone that they're tossing us
but I think that
the the general
frustration outweighs a lot
of the moment to moment
fun stuff
and I
am also
just yeah I'm kind of
on the fence between
really my
my opinion
and whether
like I just
have annoyed moments
or like
oh that's neat
moments in my
memory so I'm gonna
say it's also
like definitely a play it
just to kind of
get a vibe
for it but not an
essential game. Joe?
Yeah I really
do want to
like this more than I
did and when I booted it up
I was like oh I'm
excited like I'm
in for for like
an adventure and you know
that's always what I love
about a game is just like
if it's a long satisfying adventure
I think that
just it felt like
the game was getting in the
way of itself
a lot like there's
it seems like there's a lot
of cool stuff going on
but it was
stopping me from experiencing
it in a way
that I wanted to
now maybe
I do need to go back
and like rewire my
my expectations
a little bit as like
this is like about
figuring out
each puzzle and solving
it like remembering them
and getting back to this point
and all that but as
as I played
it I I really
didn't love it
I really was was disappointed
with it so I definitely
can't vote at essential
we briefly
talked about shadow gate
at the beginning of this episode
and before we started
Joe you had
mentioned that you recently
picked up a copy of
solstice those are
two games that I had
on here in my notes
section of just like
if there was some way
to bring them up I feel like
here in the wrap up section
would be the best
not necessarily
like ranking
these against the immortal
or whatever but are
these games
complimentary are they like
you know well I could
see why I like
shadow gate more than
the immortal
like do how do you
feel about these three
games if you can
what it feels like
to me is
maybe this
is where subconsciously
I was thinking when I booted
it up was that this seems
like it's going to be
shadow gate
combined with
what's it called with solstice
and maybe it
is but I
think that
like shadow
gate has that
that like
story puzzle-y
element with a lot of
like ways to die and
figuring out how to
not die kind of
thing and I like that
about it whereas solstice
has the
like yeah it's
a little it's it's a
action
adventure quote unquote
asymmetric game
that's like more cerebral
and I feel like I'm
I'm
instead of being an
action-y person I'm being
more like I have to
think and puzzle solve
and stuff and I love
both of those things I just
feel like this did not put
them together if you're
asking me like how where I
would place these I'd have
to play them all again to
get a a one
two three but this
is my three I know
that I just don't know which
is my one and which is my two
I would suspect that
shadowgate is my number
one based
on remembering how much I
remember liking that I
don't know did we all
vote solstice
essential I got to
imagine I did but I
don't remember I remember
really liking it though
I don't think it
got there yeah
well one thing that
I'm gonna throw a fourth
game in here
just as
just as a
bit of a comparison
in this
game there is actually
like a portal
puzzle
where you
have to put weight on
a platform
to open a
door and
that made
me start thinking of
like why why is
portal so
like there's
so many reasons why portals
fun or whatever but it's not
a twitch shooter
or like a
twitch action
game and
a cerebral
like puzzle
game you
have time
to think and when
you are trying to
get time to think in this
game you've
got bats coming at
you so
I just
think it's like these
features don't
really mix that well
when you're
kind of always
on your feet
trying to like swat
bats basically
and also like oh
how am I supposed to
get the spores into
the king's room and
get out fast enough
like I just I
don't think it really meshes well
all together
with those two different
aspects of things
I really
hate those bats
yeah
haha haha!!!!!!!!!!!! Thank you.